how's your off season been going bro
it's been going really good it's been
going really good yeah we uh
first first-time homeowners so
um you know that's been great wife is uh
three months no five months into her
pregnancy now so
you know that's coming along so um yeah
our daughter's our daughter's three so
our second was on the way yeah we're
everything's great man no no complaints
i i tell you first and foremost
congratulations on that new contract you
talked about your family it was
definitely well deserved had to make you
feel good man at the broncos
they they really value who you are and
and what you bring to the table
yeah yeah 100 and that's you know
through that whole through that whole
process especially here it meant more
here than it would have you know
somewhere else just because
i spent the last five years playing here
you know establishing relationships
building you know a relationship with
the community uh you know with the
coaches and everything um it just meant
more here to say like this is our guy we
want him to stay here
and um it just meant the world so you
know i was i know i said that a lot in
like interviews and with all these other
people but it really meant the world
that like
i wanted to be here and it was mutual
like we want you here and so we're gonna
get it done
how nice is it to have so many veteran
players in that secondary with you bryce
callahan kareem jackson yourself um kyle
fuller who i thought the bears was
absolutely crazy for letting go and then
you know you got some depth with the
drafting of patrick's routine
man i'm i don't think i've been
this excited in a minute um i think i
was i was like jumping through the roof
when i heard korea was coming back now
obviously i was you know texting him on
the side like
i'm saying we got got some pieces coming
in
you know we could use you again
obviously and um for me it's just all
about calmness like i operate i operate
really well when we're out there on the
field and everything can be hectic like
when you got a veteran group like that
in the back end everything's just calm
like nothing really throws you off
you're not surprised by a formation a
certain route combination of play
um it's just calmness right we get to
the sideline
they get paid to they might get us on a
you know route combo this down the other
come to the sideline it's calm no no
point in the finger no blame
none of that it's just like hey all
right this is what we saw this is our
rules this is our adjustments a lot of
the times like
obviously everyone talks about you know
coaches being your teammates too it's
just like we're all there figuring it
out it's calm and that's like that's one
of the things i appreciate the most with
those guys man having so much wisdom
over the years of them playing um and
they i think you know the biggest piece
of the puzzle in my opinion is kareem a
guy that played corner guy that played
nickel now he's playing safety and so he
sees the field
a lot differently than you know a guy
like myself play a little bit of
coronary college but a guy like myself
will see it because he's seen it from he
knows what it's like to be a corner that
has to do this and what body presence
looks like and so he's coaching me up
like i says this on paper jay but really
like this is what the coroner is looking
for because this is what route
combinations they're looking at in this
formation and things like that so
the the the veteran back in man has been
i'm
you know me i'm uh hey i'm happy
speaking of which when i watch you on
tape it seems like coach fangio has you
doing some different things you're not
just a deep middle safety you come down
i've covered i've seen you cover the
tight end you're in the box you're
playing over the slots sometimes you're
all over the field do you think that
best suits who you are and your your
abilities
yeah for sure i think i think a part of
it especially in today's league um you
got to be able you know we're seeing
that we're seeing a shift
in my opinion
and the way that you have to play the
games with linebackers and safeties
right you got to have linebackers that
can fill the run safeties that can fill
the run but you also got to be able to
play
some some base sometimes against 11
personnel or things like that where
you're asking your safeties you're
asking your linebackers to cover tight
ends to cover the slot receivers um so
that you can you can be able to to
function at a higher level a lot of
times teams get you a nickel and can
still run the ball really well
and
you know that's a wrap and so you got to
be able to be able to adjust and to be
able to do those things and so i think
that best fits my my skill set being
able to come down um you know the
biggest thing that that that we do
uh you know both kareem and i is that
you know we like to think that we're
interchangeable so we'll play that left
and right side try not to give any tips
of this is the strong side i feel it's
the weak side of the field and i think
all that works in our favor because
the guys that get paid the most are the
quarterbacks if you can mess them up
just just a tick that guys like chubb
and von will get there a lot faster
justin you mentioned
playing left and right and that's one of
the things that i've always liked to do
with my stapes the same thing not you
know keying who's gonna rotate down
who's gonna rotate back anything like
that but you guys play extremely well
all for one another talk about patrick
pat certain and what he brings and what
advice would you give him just
transitioning first round pick newly
acquired guy in the nfl
yeah it's always you know when you're
especially i'm just going to talk
specifically about pat but you know when
he when he's coming in like he was in
there a couple times first team reps and
it was seamless transition
a lot of a lot of the communication part
there are a lot of things that the
little details like they may have called
it something else at alabama but he gets
he understands the concept of it and
that's just like that's just where it is
now so you know i told pat like hey
don't get frustrated on terminology at
this point you know we're this is just
otas you know we get to camp we'll iron
those things out we'll [ __ ] we'll
eventually get in the game plan right
now everything's just vanilla this
doesn't look as clean as it's gonna look
in camp and you know we get into game
plans throughout the weeks so everything
you know don't trip on the little you
know in terms of the terminology the
little details we'll iron all those
things out but in terms of him you know
stepping in day one um otas you know
there's that little stick where kyle
wasn't here um and things like that so
he was in the mix and then the rotation
um it was a seamless transition i mean
he's a guy that came in
understands conceptually what's going on
um and like i said you know terminology
and stuff will
will pick up but
the way he's out there and just
competing already with the with the ones
it just
it's like he's been there already so i'm
excited to play with him now you got
bradley chubb you got bond miller in
front of you as a safety
how does that affect you and your
abilities to be more aggressive to take
more chances having those guys up front
knowing that when they're healthy
they're gonna get out to the quarterback
oh yeah i mean that just opens up
uh that's opens up so much on the
defensive side of the ball and it helps
me you know like you said i can be more
aggressive on broadcom maybe you know
maybe before if i know
uh we were you know a little bit dinked
up and uh maybe the rush wasn't there as
much as it would be with you know guys
like mine and shove in there and things
like that but
um
as a safety i know like those guys were
in there the quarterback poster in there
man this ball is coming out it's it's
whatever they're looking for they can
get they're going to look for some type
of key depending on whatever their keys
are for the week and that ball is coming
outside safety i know i could be
aggressive on these routes i can you
know i'm looking for now in film i'm
looking for
okay when we get this when i get this
formation and i'm in this call i'm
jumping this route because i know
i got bonnie chubb coming if i get this
type of route combination i can jump
this i got help here this that the other
whereas like if you don't have a
consistent rush like that you're more
hesitant they can hold on to the ball
longer we know routes get made up and
you know receivers the short threats
start going deep deep threats are coming
back short so those are the types of
things that you think about but yeah
with the with our with the type of rush
that on paper that we have right now man
um
as a guy in the back end i'm excited
coach fangio he's gotten some criticism
and but what makes him the right guy
for this job what do you guys see in him
every single day that makes him the
right guy for this job that other people
from the outside don't really understand
yeah and and that's the thing you know
it's always it's so you always block out
that outside noise i know you know as a
you know as a former as a great and so
you can't you can't listen to what other
people are saying and this that and the
other there are a lot of times where
you know on you look at the tv and you
see a busted coverage
and that's the player's fault you know
coach calls up a great coverage you
would never know on tv because you
should see what's on there like why
would they run this
well he caught a great defense a call we
just didn't execute it and there's
things there's and then you know there's
things like that that happen but i mean
coach vic man he's he's really
locked in and tuned in every single week
to the game plan and it's not it's not
his way or the highway it's
interacting kareem justin becomes
yourself what are y'all seeing out there
this is our game plan for the first
couple drives well now they're starting
to move the ball we need to adjust what
are you seeing what should what are what
are some tools we need to use like those
are the things that people don't see on
you know on tv or they don't get to see
in the press conferences that as a
player i appreciate because it's it's
winning football it's not all about me
all about my scheme all about this it's
what do we need to do to win this game
and i know that hasn't transitioned to
the win-loss record column um and i'm
not going to make all the excuses in the
world but
i'm just excited for it
i'll just say this and a big part of it
is the instability at the quarterback
position and my question to you is do
you pay
how much attention do you pay to the
quarterback situation having teddy there
and drew there
yeah i've i've always been i've always
been outspoken about um drew and i've
always i've always admired i said when
we got teddy i've always admired teddy's
game from afar you know he was a north i
mean he played at miami northwestern and
um you know in high school and i'm a
south florida kid and i used to go watch
him play
um and obviously went on to louisville
and you know i just always been an
admirer of his game so um when you know
when i heard you know we got him and you
know he came out here and you know we've
just been chopping up i'm excited and i
think i think too like competition at
every level is healthy that's the only
way your team is going to get better
right i don't want someone that comes
that's going to come in and think like
the job is just theirs they don't have
to work for it
obviously myself included and so the
same way with the quarterback position
man i want the best man to win the job
if that's true it's going to be true
it's going to play out through training
camp if that's teddy it's going to be
teddy and then obviously everyone's been
you know with the buzz of aaron rodgers
and what's going on there
um to that type of stuff i don't really
pay attention to because then i'm
getting into i'm not a what-ifs guy so
i don't really if you know if it happens
then it's like okay now i'm focused on
it but until then you know my
quarterbacks as right now are drew and
teddy and those guys are competing and
they're the ones at this point that are
going to help our football team be
successful
as a team you guys come in and you meet
and you talk you interact do you guys
hammer out specific goals like hey we
want to win the division or we want to
go on a road and do this we want to do
that do you guys
like as a team come out with specific
goals saying hey we want to win the
division we're trying to go to the
playoffs or because you know my old
teams back in 03 and 04 and we never
really came out and said we just said
hey we want to take it one day at a time
do we have to do which side of it are
you guys on the team that
takes the humble approach or the team
that says hey look our goal is to win
the division so we can get into playoffs
every single year
yeah i feel like you know the last
couple of years it was the humble route
right like hey we're focused one game at
a time one week at a time and it's true
and that's not taken away from that at
all but really man this year after
having a couple of years like we had and
the division play that we've had i just
i like it's just there's something
around here that you could tell it's
just not sitting right with the
organization and the players here so
our um are saying you know so to speak
kind of early in otas right now but it's
win the west and we're in the afc west
and obviously it's been it's been a you
know a couple years a couple games now
with the um not you know not beating the
chiefs and kind of trading blows with
the chargers and raiders and so we just
want to get back to winning the west
that's that's that's what the broncos do
and so
um that's the biggest thing here like
whatever it takes you know win the west
and that's not taken away from the other
games on our schedule because we know
how important those are to win the west
right but it's that's the thing man we
need to win the west that's that's what
the broncos do and that's what we need
to get back to doing no offend is a kid
man i watch him on tape and this dude
reminds me of grump a faster grunk he is
athletic he can catch
um it just seems like he's a really good
player tell me about some of the
matchups that you have with him in um in
camp
man i'm i'm so thankful for knowing one
that he's on my team that we get to you
know i don't have to see him on top of
the scene you know kelsey and darren
waller like we got our own we got our
own guy you know y'all got a game plan
for noah so the other thing too is um
like you said you know he has he has
those
he has those tangible things from other
tight ends that just makes his game
unique and it's really it's really good
uh practice for myself going up against
someone like noah because i do feel game
ready when i'm going up against guys
like kelsey guys like you know waller um
and things like that so
i'm excited i think noah is a great he's
going to be a great tight end in this
league for years to come yeah i agree
with him
i'm excited man i'm excited for him i'm
really excited
juwan james how did his situation
open your eyes and make you realize that
yeah this is a game that we play but
this is still a business
yeah it was tough um then i and i had
and i had texted juwan and i
communicated with him too i'm really
upset and i told him i was like i get
the business side you know with the
organization and the broncos but i'm i'm
i'm really more upset with the with the
pa
and
with the i feel like the lack of uh
the lack of kind of having his back and
now i'm not saying there should have
been like they could do something and
just maybe you know make it all go away
or find ways to get them this that and
the other but i just even mean like a
statement or something of some sort to
where
you know this whole thing's been going
on in the off season you know we we know
what happened last year with not playing
um or not having otas and we we had the
season that we had um as a union and and
saw that it was a pretty successful you
know without fans and this that any
other but but
not but then you know you're telling you
you know the message is telling guys not
to show up not to do this we don't need
otas but here's a guy that's you know
trying to stick with his with his
brothers in arms and trying to find a
way to do the right thing and it's
unfortunate what happened and then
there's no if there's at least no
statement behind like hey
you know that's that's what was really
disheartening for me and you know juwan
and i talked about it a little bit but i
was really happy to see him get picked
up um you know with the ravens and he's
he's going to be fine man he's a guy you
know we didn't get to see much of him in
denver but i've seen i've seen him in
practice and he's going to be he's going
to be fine i'm i'm happy for him i got
to ask you man because i love your game
because
you're athletic
you can tackle you can do everything you
can cover you play corner in college i
understand that but who are some of the
safeties that you kind of grew up
watching like if if you had to describe
yourself
justin simmons who are the combination
of safeties that you that make up justin
simmons is it a little bit of troy
palamalu is it a little bit of sean
taylor is it a little bit of ed reed
give me the perfect justin simmons
combination of safeties
put me on the spot man i mean there's
there's there's a there's a bunch and i
wouldn't say like i'll say the guy that
i used to watch like for the passion of
the game that i used to love watching
was brian dawkins i just loved like i
just love the way he he approached the
game by no means do i think i do it in
the same breath there's guys like that
that's just like you know it's a
once-in-a-lifetime you know generational
type of type of energy and talent you
know a guy like brian dawkins but hey
hold on hold on hold on let me just say
this yeah brian dawkins was a bad dude
but that's you
yeah but you that's the way you play you
play this green way and that's a hall of
famer and when i watch tape and that's
why i was so excited to get you on
because i've watched you and i just felt
like that you haven't really gotten the
respect nationally and that's what
happened to me when i played for the
chargers i played there played great was
outstanding but only went to a couple
pro bowls because we were constantly
constantly losing but a guy like you you
see your talent you see the play-making
ability and then people want to like man
they paid him that type of money yeah
they paid him because he can play he's
really really good so i just love your
humility and everything the one question
i want to ask you um what is it going to
take ultimately for this team to get
over that hump and get into the playoffs
and win the west like you talked about
yeah i wholeheartedly believe it's going
to be it's going to come defensively and
that's no shade on any other
phase of our game special teams offense
but to have the type of guys that we
have um just on looking on paper you
know kyle darby i'm not gonna go down
the whole list because i know obviously
i know everybody but i'm not gonna go
down the whole list but the guys that we
the guys that we acquired the guys that
were hurt last year that are coming back
you know chubb was hurt the year prior
came back had a pro bowl year you know
now he's now he's going to be coming
back another year healthy motivated
confident um i think it's going to fall
on the defense man we obviously play
uh you know powerhouse offenses like you
know the chargers the raiders had a
great offense last year then you know
the chiefs are always at the top of the
you know the offensive you know yards
per games and things like that so
defensively man like we don't need to
make game shootouts um every week you
know we need to be able to handle our
business and be able to create turnovers
for our offense give them more
possessions be able to stop the run
execute in the passing game with the
secondary that we have and those are
those are the tangible things you know
the road map to winning the west and i
can't control what the offense does
whatever they do is what they do but
defensively we can control a lot of the
game setting our offense up with more
possessions things like that i'm
shortening the field whatever the case
may be and that's what it's going to
take for us to win the west and it's
going to fall on the defensive hands
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports